taking you now back to Washington DC and
Capitol Hill where we can see one is
appointed to act as prosecutors in the
Senate trial of President I'm speaking
right now that's used in the Clinton
trial to begin with and this is I think
most indicative in the Clinton trial
both Senate leadership worked out a
bipartisan proposal for how the trial
would be conducted that obviously has
not happened here Senator McConnell did
not consult at all I was Senator Schumer
on the contents of this text I would
imagine that Senator Schumer only got to
see it to probably around the same time
that we did in the house and the reason
this was kept hidden is that it does not
prescribe a process for a fair trial and
the American people desperately want to
believe that the Senate will give both
the President and the House of
Representatives a fair trial this
resembles nothing like the Clinton
proceeding for the first point in the
Clinton case if we're truly following
the Clinton precedent all of the
documents were provided before the trial
more than 90,000 of them does this
resolution provide for the President to
provide the document Ryle no it does not
it leaves that question of whether the
house will ever see these documents
where the American people will ever see
these documents to the end and only the
end with no guarantee that this material
will ever be shown to the house or to
the American people that is a profound
departure from the Clinton trial without
the documents you can't make important
judgments about even which witnesses
should be called what questions should
be asked of the witnesses when you do so
that is a profound departure from the
Clinton precedent on the subject of
witnesses it is also a deep departure
from Clinton where all of the witnesses
testified before the Senate trial the
issue in the Clinton trial was not
whether they would testify they had
testified already they had been
interviewed already some dozens of times
a question the Clinton trot was will
they be recalled will be there will they
be required to testify again
and that question was answered in the
affirmative here though if we're
following the Clinton precedent all of
these witnesses should testify should be
deposed before the trial begins not
after the trial is over
so this is not at all the model used in
the Clinton case as well this relation
even goes so far in another departure
from the Clinton precedent to say
they're not even going to admit the
evidence that was received in the house
that they're going to even postpone the
decision about whether any of the
witness testimony will actually be part
of the record and finally they are
compressing the time of the trial
whereas the Clinton trial managers had
six hours a day to present over course
of days
they're now presenting that we doubled
the amount of time each day so that the
proceedings can conceivably go well into
the night when apparently Senator
McConnell hopes the American people will
not be watching this is not a process
for a fair trial this is the process for
a rigged trial this is the process if
you do not want the American people to
see the evidence this is a process you
use if you want to hand in hand working
in concert with the president allow the
President to continue to obstruct the
Congress and deny the truth the American
people thankfully however we know the
truth the evidence is already
overwhelming and that evidence is that
the president abused the power of his
office will held hundreds of millions of
dollars of need military aid to an ally
at war in order to coerce that Ally into
interfering in our election and then
when he was caught obstructed to
Congress to cover it up that truth is
inescapable no matter how Meccano wishes
to structure this trial but we will be
appealing to the manager we will be
appealing as managers to the senators
today to live up to the oath they have
just taken to do impartial justice and
to hold a fair trial and we're happy to
respond to questions
he had something here this one add that
this fixation on the Clinton precedent
is weird the Clinton trial was conducted
fairly but distorting what happened
there shouldn't make a difference the
question is should you have a fair trial
now any intelligent person knows that in
any trial whether it's for robbing a
bank or for subverting the Constitution
of the United States the accusers in
this case the House of Representatives
bring in all the witnesses and all the
evidence the defenders can bring in all
the evidence they want that's how you
have a trial to be debating whether you
should have the evidence admitted to be
debating whether you should allow
witnesses is to be debating whether you
should have a cover-up by definition
there is no other way to look at it it
doesn't matter if how it was done some
time ago it's done very fairly as it
happened to some time ago but it doesn't
matter it cannot be used as an excuse
the only reason to oppose bringing a
witness is to cover-up because you're
afraid of what the witness will say the
question before the Senate is do the
Republican senators want to be complicit
in the cover-up of the President any
senator who votes to deny a witness who
votes to deny evidence is voting to
cover-up the president's crimes and
subversion of the Constitution there's
no other way about it there is no
conceivable reason to deny witnesses to
say you cannot bring in the evidence the
House of Representatives cannot bring in
the evidence there's no reason I mean
it's obvious to say what do they fear
why won't they bring in the witnesses
because they are afraid of what the
witnesses will say but there's no trial
in this country
in which you wouldn't admit the relevant
witnesses in which it's even a question
that will be a decision that the house
should make not that the center should
prescribe to go late into the evening
look there is a wealth of evidence to
present here and we should have the
opportunity to present the case as the
house chooses to present its case not to
go late into the evening when Senator
McConnell evidently hopes the public may
not be watching and so we'll make
decisions about how long that our case
should go within the rules that are
prescribed but I think the question is
what is the Senators interest what is
Senator McConnell's interest in
structuring the trial this way is this
about hiding the evidence from the
American people with late-night sessions
is this about just trying to get it over
with because that should not be the
motivation here Senator McConnell has
taken the same oath as every other
senator in that chamber and that is to
do impartial justice not to try to skew
the process in such a way where the
house is not permitted to put its
evidence before the American people
do it in any way no because look it this
is part and parcel of an effort to cover
up the presence misconduct that was the
whole object that is charged in article
2 of the impeachment articles and if the
Senate and the Senate leadership will
not allow the house to present its case
will not allow the calling of witnesses
or presentation of documents if Senator
McConnell makes this the first
impeachment trial in history without
witnesses or documents it will not prove
the president innocent it will merely
prove the Senate guilty of working with
the President to obstruct the truth from
coming out and so I you know I do think
that by structuring the trial this way
it furthers our case that what's going
on here really is a cover-up of evidence
to the American people well and I asked
some of my colleagues to add on as well
but look there are a number of key
witnesses I think that we know even at
the outside of the trial should be
called and they're people like John
Bolton and people like Mick Mulvaney
they're people like Michael Duffy and Mr
Blair and others but if we're proceeding
in a logical fashion if we're truly
interested in a fair trial the first
step ought to be the production of the
documents those documents will reveal
precisely who the most important
witnesses are and they may be those four
and it may be others as well let me just
give one illustration of what's being
hidden from the American people we have
text messages where high-level people in
the diplomatic corps are asking each
other
are we really withholding military aid
and as we talked about last night I
think it's crazy to withhold military
aid to pressure an ally to get help with
a political campaign that document those
documents have not been provided by the
administration they don't want the
American people to see them now we
I've seen them because cooperating
witnesses did provide them but documents
like those are being withheld from the
public that is the kind of cover-up that
the present is engaged in and the Senate
should not make itself a party to that
so you know just to conclude in terms of
witnesses we should review the documents
we should the house should have the
right to call with this is the president
should have the right to call witnesses
material witnesses not witnesses yes for
the purpose of smearing his opponent but
material witnesses that's what makes a
fair trial but let me ask my colleagues
who haven't had a chance to speak if
they'd like to add well you know it says
if you're on Judy duty a jury duty and
the judge were to come in the courtroom
and say you know I've been talking to
the defendant and we've decided I'm not
going to let the prosecution call any
witnesses and I'm not gonna let them
call a need for any documents I'm only
gonna let the prosecution read from the
cold record in the grand jury and even
then we won't necessarily decide you can
consider that as evidence that makes it
impossible to have a fair trial not just
difficult but impossible to have a fair
trial and and I think for senators who
take their oath seriously and I hope and
pray that they do this is not the fair
trial that the American people want it's
not the fair trial the American people
deserve thank you
all right Democratic House impeachment
managers speaking ahead of the start of
the president Trump's impeachment trial
in the US Senate today the Senate is
deciding on the rules governing this
trial they say that the Republican
leaders proposed rule Mitch McConnell's
proposed rules do not describe a fair
process a fair trial Adam Schiff whom we
heard from there said that this is not a
process for a fair trial and it's a
process that allows the president he
said to continue to obstruct the
Congress he also said that Mitch
McConnell's evidence and Westnet witness
rules are a departure from the Clinton
impeachment trial a lot of comparison
with the Clinton impeachment trial and
he added that this is part and parcel of
an effort to cover up the president's
misconduct stretch speak to Heidi Joe
Castro on Capitol Hill forests Heidi the
dispute over witnesses really is the key
friction point between Democrats and
Republicans in anticipation of the start
of this trial in the Senate
what can Democrats really do about it at
this stage well they certainly do not
have the numbers to vote down this
resolution Foley as you know Republicans
control the Senate and there would have
to be at least four of them who wrote
against McConnell's resolution or
approve amendments that we expect from
the Democrats and so far not a one of
those Republicans have said they're
willing to do so we're expecting a
purely partisan vote approving these
proposed trial rules in the coming hours
what Democrats can do and as you saw
them just now making that press
conferences make this pitch to the
American people to try to communicate to
voters what a fair trial should look
like this was quite an educational press
conference in a sense you saw Adam
Schiff the lead house manager the
prosecutor
this case saying that there is no fair
trial without evidence and he's pointing
out this key point of contention that
really has incensed Democrats about this
Republican proposal and that is the lack
of a guarantee to introduce the
currently existing evidence into the
trial record what does that mean in
layman's terms well it means that there
will that the 17 witnesses who we've
heard from in the last month and the
text messages so much that we've
reported on that that would not warm any
sort of legal basis for the Senators to
consider when determining whether or not
the president is guilty of these charges
and thus should be removed from office
rather without that guarantee that this
evidence should be considered the
Senators may have an excuse to say that
there's no legal basis for the arguments
that we'll hear so we're really
Republicans trying to take away the
fundamental building blocks the legal
building blocks the Democrats say are
essential to arguing their case and to
proving what they think is abuse of
power and obstruction of Congress on
part of the president and that is what
has them so outraged because it is a
extreme departure from what we saw in
the last impeachment trial that of Bill
Clinton 21 years ago that is the house
evidence at that point or that the
Independent Counsel evidence was
automatically part of the trial record
for President Clinton's impeachment
trial that will not be the case here for
Trump it doesn't mean that it can't be
called into the record later on it just
means that postponing that decision and
and not having that guarantee means more
partisan opportunities for Republicans
to move to not include that evidence and
of course the same concerns regarding
the Democrats demand
four more witnesses to be called and
that is why you just heard the
Democratic prosecutors the house
managers say that this will not be a
fair trial at all because under this
proposal Republicans they say are trying
to basically get rid of all the evidence
that which is existing and also no
guarantees for calling or for the
development of more evidence with new
witnesses to be called okay Heidi thank
you very much for the moment Heidi Joe
Castro live for us on Capitol Hill